so it looks like the Fantastic 4 is
going to be a little bit different than
we thought they were going to be in the
MCU I'm not speaking only of the movie
in general but the actual family from
what we've heard the Fantastic 4 film is
going to be really interesting
especially if you consider the fact that
it's coming in before Avengers Secret
Wars and Secret Wars is supposed to give
us a soft reboot of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so the movie was already very
interesting however we have learned some
new details about the film that make it
even more interesting and in fact if
these reports are true then that means
Marvel is about to introduce some
characters who are going to be complete
game changers for the MCU in fact the
Fantastic 4 film is going to introduce
many gamechanging characters in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe of course the
Fantastic 4 team themselves are a game
changer but the villains and Other Side
characters that they're going to
introduce could be equally as important
and exciting so we'll break down these
new reports talk about the characters
coming in the Fantastic 4 talk about the
cast and talk about when to expect our
first look from the Fantastic 4 film so
if you're new be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest Fantastic
4 news and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month so right away the
first piece of news about the Fantastic
4 which should get fans excited is that
it looks like the film is going to begin
production and filming and everything
January 15th of 2024 that is less than 2
months away which means several
different things one it means that we
should have the cast for The Fantastic 4
relatively soon because here's the thing
Marvel Studios knows that once they
begin production and they begin filming
people are going to talk and Paparazzi
are going to take photos so ultimately
what that means is the second they begin
filming we're going to know who the cast
of The Fantastic 4 is there's going to
be leaks there are so many people who
work on sets and information just gets
out plus like I mentioned you have
Paparazzi companies who literally their
entire jobs are to try and take photos
of characters on sets that way they can
sell them or put them online or both we
always get set photos even with
Spider-Man no way home which was all
filmed mostly inside we still got
sneaked photos of Toby Maguire Andrew
Garfield and Tom Holland on set so
Marvel Studios is going to want to beat
the paparazzi and the leaks for the
reveal of the Fantastic forecast so we
should be getting that relatively soon
hopefully within a month and director
Matt shakman has already stated he's
really eager to tell us and since the
strikes just ended the official cast is
probably almost locked in if you haven't
heard Pedro Pascal seems to be confirmed
to be plain Reed Richards aka Mr
Fantastic Vanessa Kirby is supposedly
going to be PL Sue storm and the rest we
don't actually know yet however we do
know about the villain or I should say
villains and two other really
interesting characters reportedly coming
to the movie the first one and you've
most likely heard about this is Galactus
from what we've heard two actors are
currently in the running to play the
voice of Galactus we're not sure if the
entire character of galatis is going to
be CGI or if they'll use the face of one
of these actors for the face of Galactus
and simply put the helmet on him but
we've heard that two actors are in the
running and those actors are Antonio
benderz and Javier bardam I like both
actors but I think I'd lean more towards
Antonio Banderas but let me know what
you think about these two choices in the
comments down below then there is
reportedly going to be a big change to
one of the most iconic Heralds of
Galactus and Marvel characters out there
the Silver Surfer according to a couple
of different insiders the Silver Surfer
in the MCU might be a female with the
recent report coming from Jeff Snider
who simply said and yes you can expect
to see a female Silver Surfer and before
we get talking about how this could be a
variant the answer to that is yes and no
and if you're mad at the Silver Surfer
possibly being a woman in the movie this
might help a little bit the Fantastic 4
movie is reportedly going to be set in a
different Universe than the 616 Main MCU
Universe we've talked about this a lot
on the channel so I won't spend too much
time on it but basically from what we've
heard and know the Fantastic 4 by the
end of their film will actually lose to
galatis but the TVA will then show up
and then take the Fantastic Four team
away to be able to save them and get
them ready for the multiversal war and
fight against King the Conqueror which
of course is going to come in secret
Wars this means that when the Fantastic
Four are in our main MCU timeline after
the reboot we could have another galatis
and another Silver Surfer who is
actually a male like he is in the comics
I actually have to say I am kind of
tired of the gender swapping just to do
it especially with an iconic character
like the Silver Surfer but hey let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below and like I said we
still have two other crazy interesting
characters to talk about in this video
but first big thank you to Highland
titles for sponsoring this video before
we leap back into the world of
superpowers I've got something truly
extraordinary for our Noble listeners
imagine that you yes you can become a
lord or lady for just $30 buying a plot
of land from Highland tile.com will
allow you to make use of a Scottish
tradition in which land owners are given
a courtesy title with more than 15,000
five-star reviews The High titles gift
pack is an incredibly popular gift and
the Highland titles app available from
the app and play stores is a new
addition that allows you to explore a 3D
replica of the land choose the location
of your plot and decorate it using
augmented reality embrace the Majesty as
every purchase helps to conserve the awe
inspiring heroic beauty of the Scottish
Wilderness you can soar into the world
of nobility My Friends by visiting
Highland ties.com and become a lord or
lady today use the discount code code
Cosmic to receive 25% off your order
that's Highland ties.com and use code
Cosmic so these two other characters are
actually going to be a part of the
Fantastic 4 family and I mean that very
literally because the two characters
that are rumored to be appearing in the
Fantastic for film are the Son and
Daughter of Reed Richards in Seuss storm
Franklin and Valeria Richards two
incredibly important and powerful
characters and The Game Changer in the
MCU is Franklin Richards Frank is
literally one of the most OP characters
in Marvel history ever you're talking
about a character who at one point in
time resurrected Galactus and used him
as his puppet literally he was using
galatis to do his own will and galatis
simply obeyed and did what he was told
his character basically goes on to
become a God and according to history of
the Marvel Universe Franklin Richards is
supposed to survive the end of his
universe and pass on to the next like
galatis has done this character is
seriously op but there could be a very
very specific reason that Marvel Studios
is bringing this character into the MCU
and that reason is at one point Franklin
Richards literally restores the
Multiverse in the comics the Multiverse
literally collapses due to the incursion
crisis but Franklin Richards uses his
Godlike abilities to help restore it and
this could actually be how the fantastic
IC four Come From Another Universe but
then after Secret Wars end up in our
main Universe if it's Reed Richards and
Franklin Richards restoring the
Multiverse at the end of Secret Wars it
would make sense that they would end up
in our main timeline especially if their
Universe gets completely and fully
destroyed we are assuming that not every
universe is going to be able to be
brought back to life or restored but
only some will remain after the events
of Secret Wars It's Made very clear by
Loki that universes or timelines can be
completely and permanently destroyed but
at the same time we saw Loki restore the
Multiverse so most likely something
pretty similar is going to happen at the
end but don't bat your eye at Valeria
Richards either because she is still one
of the most powerful characters out
there she was originally Valeria Von
Doom But ultimately her story in Marvel
Comics leads her to be the daughter of
Reed Richards and Sue storm and the
sister of Franklin Richards she has
amazing abilities one she is a genius
much like her father she has has
superhuman strength she has
invulnerability also invisibility and
she can time travel she can create a
force field much like her mother and she
can use telekinesis to a certain level
as well so these two characters who are
going to be brought into the Fantastic 4
movie reportedly are going to be game
changers this report came from the geeky
cast so take it with a grain of salt but
they State according to someone who
recently reached out there is talks of
casting Franklin and Valeria Richards
two names have popped up for Franklin
and two for Valeria it seems they are
going for a little older and are working
around Pedro Pascal if this is true so
if these two characters enter the MCU
and the Fantastic 4 film they're not
going to be infants but they're going to
be a little bit older perhaps teenagers
and if it's anything like the comics
that means they're already going to be
two of the most powerful characters in
the MCU so a lot to look forward to with
the Fantastic 4 but let me know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all things Fantastic 4 in
the MCU you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof